his hit show crashing is in season three
on HBO airs Sundays at 10:00 p.m. every
single week he is the host of the you
made it weird podcast which is only
fitting because I do believe he is the
only guest in the history of the Rich
Eisen show whose first word ever uttered
was the f-word he is Pete Hall by the
way no now the the record in our old
podcast days for cursing because this
show is yes and but we were able to
bleep that stuff out until Timothy
Olyphant broke it yes
Oh laughs and he did he what'd he say
yeah points I can't really say oh wow
syllables are more he said sarsaparilla
pretty much I can't believe I know he
didn't say that use the word fair
saddlebags by the way that's now HBO
humor right here
oh wow keep it on the HBO families we
twist you know you are such a Samantha
Time Warner merger I mean it's called
synergy P that is synergy another
polysyllabic word oh my god the word
that I just used and not the word that I
used that's correct
that was monosyllabic was that you keep
them a good bow shot away when we
started pot to your get co-host when we
when we started the show no no we need
to it's I guess to use the old explore
space you can explore the studio I guess
I don't know I can barely see I'm sorry
it's Mike Mike Mike on the right you're
being blocked like remember the police
they hated each other mm-hm
so like the drummer would set up the
cymbal so he couldn't see sting totus
for Mike and I right now are you sting
and he's like this I'm gonna let you be
stick a tease sting not 90s linen pants
sting your cooler sting not enlightened
linen pants one earring great pole
meditating in between
- tantric and I say sex you can say
testicle it was in the clip that's a
polysyllabic - oh my geez I'm back on
counting syllables with rich eyes it's
only fitting that you try to shutter
this show since she prevented me no I
heard in the green room that we had
pilots up at TBS at the same time we
were dueling pilots I can't believe it I
yeah I didn't know at the time that you
existed
yeah as a pilot yeah I'm sure you didn't
know that I existed it has a buzz and
you shot a pilot I shot him I'm so sorry
there's like this no I know I'm not
sorry for you I'm sorry for all like I
know here you can take your hits yes I'm
trying to make it sports themed well
done you can put your shoulder into the
the arm bag you can run drills and
squats you can play quarters and heads
and then the kick for the punt and the
fumble I know you know how to do a blitz
yes is what I'm saying yes you do but
like what stinks is that all of us show
folk even Mike who I can't say have to
deal with these little heart breaks
these upsets if you will yes that you
that you at the last second you gotta
keep yeah down the field side kick until
there's a yeah and I'm sick games over I
only know that from Madden you always do
an onside kick
even if it's the first quarter yeah this
is your first play yeah doing onside
kick never punt it's a video game why
are you punting what are you tired
you're sitting on a couch go for it
onside kick Hail Mary every play it's
it's I don't know of any gamers that are
trying to err on the side of coal let's
make this realistic you should punt you
idiot go for the two-point conversion
it's a game you're a Madden player I
used to play Madden quite a bit be the
Cowboys that's all I remember why did
you stop playing Madden I don't know it
got too realistic once it was like the
last of things scared you off no it
would they they made it so like one of
the controllers controlled the
quarterbacks head like you'd have to
turn as
and and like you'd be a better thrower
if you I can't do that I'm here to be a
winner
that's if I want to be bad at football
I'll go outside and throw a football I
want to be good at football I want to be
Thomas Brady and his and his whoring
coach or whatever is I want a game where
I can be him and go get a lady of the
evening or the morning as it happened he
wouldn't saw a lady of the morning
Wow he said I interviewed him unibrow I
interviewed unibrow on my show montage
was he on
he was on the Pete Home Show on the Pete
Holmes
I had Aaron Rodgers on so the show that
got made and put on the air by TBS to
put on after Conan instead of mine yes
would have made my dreams come true I
hear you I interviewed people you would
have cared about and I didn't give I
called him unibrow I interviewed James
Harden Kyrie Irving people that you
would have been like Shaq all these
people I just talked about how tall they
were and what they had for breakfast so
were you fighting I'm only teasing I
looked up what they did I find I did my
best I was no Rich Eisen but I did my
best to interview these because my
producer Nick Bernstein just now works
at Corden he loved sports and he would
be like I think it would be funny for
you to talk to these people and it was
it was I like a nod like Aaron Rodgers
we were talking about did my podcast and
he heard he and I are chums
and I think it's because I don't care
about football it's refreshing for him I
think when you have an athlete on and
you're funny and you can be engaging
with them yeah they understand you're
not gonna ask them the tough sports so
that's a safe place you make it a safe
place I make it a safe place like for me
right now please
what was your show called the one that
didn't go the Rich Eisen pilots Rich
Eisen pilot I understand but here you
are this is way nicer than what you
would have gotten had that Shogun
very happy it's all it's all for a
reason I'm not just trying to synergize
am i using that correctly
that's what crashing is about my wife
leaves me and then it leads to the life
that I was supposed to have to say in
the morning kind of like so are you
aware of the NFL Network beat that's
they have a network now 16 years 16 16
years they've had it I know Nessun I was
on I wrote that work
I wrote that jingle having fun I've been
on the Superbowl cuz I was the e-trade
baby
[Music]
my dad years I was I've always tried my
dad loves the Patriots he loves the the
Red Sox and the Bruins and the Celtics
and all that very much so I've always
been trying to get my father's attention
like any good comedian so it was a big
thrill when I got to be on the one show
that he cares about which is called the
super super ball cam in ninety billion
people see Sullivan Network is a channel
dedicated to football 24/7 24/7 six 16
years now Richie Rich is the face of the
network first-ever host you've been on
that channel for hours than anyone ever
yes Wow it is owned by all 32 owners of
the National Football League including
Patriots owner Bobby including the guy
that went to
including the owner of the Giants and
the Jets a chest that went on Jemima and
said how much for some of that sweet
syrup who cares you know him can we call
him that would be that would be viral
let's call him and be like was it worth
it it was like Mitch you're not gonna
believe me it was worth it you should
have seen it
I lost a foot I don't know I love this I
don't know how much it's worth it but I
don't think I'm gonna make that phone
call no don't do it but I know what
you're doing sometimes people tease me
and they want me to disparage hpi-o or
they want me to tease yeah I don't when
I have my show how can you disparage ugh
I don't know there's no way distracting
him I don't know why they like they know
that tension so I'm having fun with the
same tension that you have she ate that
but I you know I'm the fall guy
you're the pro let's make some easy Mack
baby when when you had Aaron Rodgers on
yes Podcast and how did you get to the
subject of UFOs how in the world did you
get on to that I love this question so
Aaron Rodgers that square-jawed miracle
man yes
came and did my podcast in a studio that
does not look like this okay it's
basically just my home and he was
wearing a hat that had like crop circles
on it okay so it happened as naturally
as it could be I was like what's up with
your hat and he's like I love aliens and
I'm not a great interviewer as you can
imagine but I was just like have you
ever seen an alien
and boom Aaron Rodgers saw an alien
that's incredible he saw a girl
purportedly there's a Molly where's
where I don't remember I just remembered
that he saw one how do you football he
could have probably grounded it he got
really good at taking it out Wow
but you picked it up in yes I did pick
it up picked it up both of us are
forgetting what happened I think that's
the fluoride in the water the government
is
does not care about the most interesting
things they said we heard that Aaron
Rodgers saw a UFO and both of us forgot
the details
what other notes in the water what other
athletes have you had on you've made it
weird
JJ reddick okay JJ reddick who's a
podcaster in his own right you think he
isn't Dean I didn't know that uh he was
wonderful I didn't see the other thing
like people didn't like JJ in college
right now right well I mean you went to
Duke so and so there's a lot of people
who don't like Duke I'm one of them why
because they went too much you like the
I don't like the Patriots don't like the
Patriots that is not the reason why we
had the helmet there the winner of the
Super Bowl every year that's a very it's
like having the picture the president up
you don't agree with it but you put it
up like the sixties well I have that we
have the winner of the Super Bowl right
there just like I see the Rams football
is in the helmet right there that's what
we call meson seen meson Sam yes indeed
what does that mean it means it up it's
a second come on you don't know you
don't know movie terms knees on field
that's a director's term no I don't know
it well you're just an actor and a
comedian well how dare you I mean the
Rams threw a football and already know
that the Rams lost to the Patriots cuz
it's stuck in the hell I didn't even
know the Rams were a team it's taken I'm
just picturing a bunch of how are you
from Boston and not into the sports
world if that's how you rebelled as you
didn't care about sports I like mom's
stuff my dad took they had season they
still have season tickets to Fenway and
they and I would go with my dad and I
just wanted to chat do they have season
tickets of the Patriots I don't know I
don't think so
not anymore it's too pricey because he
went to a lady of the morning why do we
care you people care right you know what
you guys don't care I don't care here's
my hot take go to Nevada that's the hot
tub the guy has a billion dollars
prostitution is legal in Nevada he
didn't want to be groggy for his morning
session of paid intercourse take the
flight to where it's legal get a flyer
on the street go oh is bubbles available
then go to a nice sweet bill upgrade you
you own the Patriots have some legal sex
work done to you then fly to your
important ball match you know after a
very important ball match I mean any
shows on the bubble that's not picked up
when you find this stuff we should find
out any day when is this air good ok so
please watch it which brings us all full
circle I am proud that this is live and
I'm so sorry I said the F word is all
good be actually don't nerd then I
appreciate that
I apologize not as hard as the guy that
hey bad Pete Holmes on Twitter for the
cinnamon toast crunch guys oh good to
see you guys I gotta come back that good
I love this test but I'm all revved up
now like the owner of the big games
nothing like a full release to help me
oh the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience